so the book is chock full of revelations
big
and small um but i'm going to to turn it
to you
what were the things that you found
while you were covering the race where
you said ooh
i'm gonna keep that for the book even
though
i kind of am tempted to share it with
people now like
what were like the surprises that you
saw
um that that uh you kind of held for
publication
that everyone would have been excited
about at the time
uh well again some of this i knew
because i knew it and held on to it and
some of it i
only found out about early out because
i was reporting it on the these embargo
rules uh and i think the best example is
one of the very first things that i
got that i knew would end up in the book
uh was
the scene that's in there of kamala
harris
uh deciding to run for president uh and
it's a meeting that she has in new york
uh with all of her campaign team and her
uh her sister uh who's her closest
advisor
uh and brother-in-law there and
they go through the presentations about
uh
fundraising and the schedule and how
it's all going to go
and uh and that's interesting in itself
but the moment i just knew
would be great to have is she it ends
with a moot court because harris really
is like a lawyer
deep in how she thinks about things uh
and
so they have mark elias who's the
democratic lawyer does a lot of election
law
challenges he does the uh case for
running
and uh he does this whole big speech
which ends with him saying
the house of our democracy is on fire
and we need you to be there
okay um then they turn to tony west
uh harris's brother-in-law to do the
case against running
uh and because he's family they figure
he can go at her pretty hard
and he does and says she hasn't been in
the senate for long enough and
uh she uh she was
all these things she did as a prosecutor
were terrible they were betrayal black
people and their betrayal progressives
and
blah blah blah blah all things that
ended up being real factors during
the campaign for her and he hits her
hard
and they're all sitting there thinking
like oh [ __ ]
glad he uh as the brother-in-law raised
all this
and uh and she looks at him and she goes
yeah i like some [ __ ] up um
and uh as i point out in the book she is
now vice president harris [ __ ]
is like her favorite word and she will
correct people if they put the r's into
it uh so
that's how she said it and what as i was
watching the attacks go on about her
record as a prosecutor
of course as a reporter you want to say
like i have this super juicy thing
and this is how she talked about and
this is how she dismissed it but i
couldn't use it
i'm glad that it was there for the book
um because i think it's interesting
even in retrospect uh and uh
and so that that really was
again that was i had a separate notebook
that i was keeping of
stuff that was for the book and that was
in the notebook
by january of 2019
uh in full um the whole scene of it
um uh and parts of it were in earlier
uh there were other things too uh that
uh that really surprised me i mean i
think one of the ones and because it
ended up being so relevant
also kind of relates to the vice
presidential process but knowing
just how
uh rough and vicious things got between
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren
and then knowing the story that's in the
book of how
warren once she decides to drop out is
stressing about what to do with her
endorsement
with the idea that she wants bernie
sanders to not be the nominee and she
wants joe biden to be the nominee at
that point
and whether for her the right calculated
move
is to endorse sanders so that she can
have the credibility to then call on him
to drop out
a week or two later or whether it's to
endorse biden
so that she can give him the progressive
boost uh
and in the end she didn't endorse
anybody she just didn't make no decision
but she's having these like
conversations with her staff with other
people with barack obama
it's all going on but when it comes time
for the
uh biden to think about a vice
presidential nominee
warren really wants it and what would
have really helped her at that moment
is bernie sanders saying hey i think you
should consider elizabeth
it would mean a big deal a great deal to
me to my supporters would be
a way to draw everybody in and sanders
is so
pissed about everything that went on
that he
won't say it and he won't say he won't
even bring up her name
and he kept on saying oh we're you know
when he was talking about it and they
were talking a fair amount
um he he would say oh well we're not i
don't bring up the vice presidential
stuff
and that's that was his uh way of not
uh saying anything good or bad about
warren because he didn't want to trash
her
but he could have helped her and he
decided not to and maybe
she would have been the vice
presidential nominee otherwise there
were some other concerns
the biden team had including that she
would
make she would sort of reinforce the
idea that biden looked old
uh but um
that especially and and that stuff i
started to really
get a sense of uh during the vice
presidential selection process so that
was
over the summer i was doing some
reporting people would send me i can
tell you this part but you can't use
this until later
the bernie warren interplay was
fascinating in your book
like that there was a real blow by blow
even in the beginning
when they're each deciding to run
they're taking each other's temperature
that sounds fascinating and i've
obviously been around both of them but
you know
like a dozen times i've seen them
interact with each other
would you describe them as friendly
they just they're very cordial very
cordial colleagues
uh you know that they're uh you know
like there's definitely a high degree of
familiarity um i i feel like
the the warmth um you know might have
uh gone up and down over the time like
no but what you're getting at it like
that's it right and the chapter in the
book is called not friends the first
chapter
about warren and sanders right like
because they're not you'd think that
they maybe are but they're not
um and they're like
gaming each other out over the course of
2018 to see which one was going to run
for president
uh ultimately deciding i don't care
i'm running i don't care what he does or
i don't care what she does i'm running
uh you know it comes to a head in a way
at this dinner that warren invites
sanders over to her apartment
in washington uh and like one of the
funny details in the book to me
is that sanders afterwards uh
would tell people that warren cooked for
him and warren
ordered in italian he said oh she made
lasagna for me
[Laughter]
and like that was a much more
significant thing that happened at that
dinner that's the dinner where people
may remember it blew up later that uh
warren heard him say basically he didn't
think a woman could
win um he says that what he said about
it was that he was saying
it would be hard for a woman to run and
win uh
but even just the deep details of it
of uh like how these people relate to
each other
but warren doesn't she's not much of a
cook um
so but sanders is assuming oh this
italian food that's here
she must have made it for me it was wild
for me isaac
because like the first couple of times i
was around various
candidates like there were different
levels of uh
receptivity to me where initially
they just didn't know who i was
[Laughter]
like that happened you know but but then
uh like over time they became familiar
with me and
and uh you know there's like a a degree
of
um collegiality that would get built up
um but that i remember the first time i
met elizabeth warren i was in a room
and when you're a candidate there are
certain levels of energy around you
where like you come in a room and then
people really want to talk to you
uh and so the the first time i was in
the same room as elizabeth warren was
like a fairly big democratic event in
one of the states i think it might have
been um south carolina
and then that like all these people like
flocked to her
because she was elizabeth warren and a
big deal and at the time i was not a big
deal
um and so candidates would like bigfoot
each other all the time that way no not
intentionally necessarily
they just come in and everyone here
karen um and so like the first time i
was around
elizabeth uh she didn't really have much
uh who i was and i i think it was really
only after the debate started getting
going that
that that they would start to um pick up
on
who some of the other candidates were um
but uh you know the watching people
interact with each other was fascinating
for me like it was for everyone else
uh where you'd see something going on in
the press and then you'd see the people
interact individually
well i feel like for you you had this
this strange experience where
you didn't know any of these people
beforehand so you were
sort of like a spectator of like getting
to know all these people like a lot of
america was
but on the other hand you were there you
were on the debate stage you were
in backstage at these events you were
because your candidacy was starting to
pull together and uh certainly i mean
like
when it became the moment when it became
clear to me that you were going to be
something that was a significant part of
the race
was the debate in detroit the second
debate
um when uh
i'm gonna get your exact phrasing wrong
but you there was a question about
climate change and you said well maybe
we need to consider moving a higher
ground right which was
this very uh in some ways dark
nihilistic way of looking at things but
also very practical minded because
your point was we spend a lot of time
talking about climate change and like
we're talking talking talking and the
climate keeps changing right
and i think that the reaction that that
generated to me
uh was really fascinating um
and uh and i it but it's still i think
for a lot of the other candidates
you were not it took a little bit longer
for them to plug into the fact that you
were this was
something that was really gonna catch
[Music]
you